Speaker 1: Let's talk about virtue signaling.
The right says that they are against so-called
virtue signaling.
Now, virtue signaling is when you publicly
express an opinion to try to signal that you
are morally on the right side of something
or to signal that your character is to be
respected.
And Republican Arizona Gov. Doug Ducey is
doing exactly this.
He has issued an executive order banning so-called
vaccine passports, of which there are none
in Arizona, nor were any coming as described
by his executive order.
First question, what is a vaccine passport?
Well, the executive order would ban state
and local governments in Arizona from requiring
Arizonans to provide proof of covid vaccination,
either to go into some kind of government
building or to receive something.
He tweeted about it saying, quote, I've issued
an executive order banning vaccine passports
and preventing state and local governments
from requiring Arizonans to provide their
covid-19 vaccination status to receive service
or enter an area.
Deucy going on to tweet that quote, The residents
of our state should not be required by the
government to share their private medical
information.
More on that later.
While we strongly recommend all Arizonans
get the vaccine, it's not mandated in our
state and it never will be.
Now, the logical question would be.
Was the state of Arizona about to mandate
people need to get vaccinated?
Was the state of Arizona or were municipalities
about to say you need a vaccine in order to
go to this government building or that or
no, no, no.
But this was never going to happen.
So, first of all, this executive order is
focused on something which wasn't actually
going to be taking place now.
Second question is, does this actually apply
to those who might require a vaccination like
a school or a business?
It does not.
It would not prevent that if the Phenix Suns
NBA team says, you know what, at some point
once, you know, maybe by next next season
to come to our games, you're going to need
to provide proof of vaccination.
This executive order does nothing to stop
that.
The Phenix Suns could legally do that if they
want to do it.
Schools can require vaccinations.
Schools have required vaccinations for decades
in Arizona just for different vaccines.
And so not only is this virtue signaling trash
executive order meant to stop something which
was not going to happen, which is mandatory
vaccination for Arizona or governments, municipalities
requiring the vaccine or requiring it to do
something that was never going to happen.
This is going to create anti vaccines.
Who will have heard of this?
And then they will go to a business or their
kid will need a vaccine to go to school and
they will show up and filmed themselves saying,
do see, pass the law against this.
And of course, he didn't.
The executive order is about what government
will or won't do with regard to vaccination.
It has nothing to do with businesses.
It has nothing to do with schools.
So it's it's it's a combination of pointless
virtue signaling with the addition of creating
more problems for schools and businesses who
are able to require a coronavirus vaccination.
Now, a related topic in that second tweet,
Deucy said, residents of our state should
not be required by the government to share
their private medical information.
Now, is he on the same page with that claim
when it comes to which bathroom a trans person
wants to use?
Or does he want it to be forced that they
need to provide proof of their biological
sex at birth?
Is he on the same page when it comes to women
and abortion?
Or does the phrase residents of our state
should not be required by the government to
share private medical information, only apply
to covid vaccination requirements?
This guy is pathetic.
One of the worst of the worst one of the worst
handling's in the country of the coronavirus
pandemic and now the executive order, which
doesn't actually deal with what people think
it deals with and deals only with something
that was never going to happen.
We're going to have more coverage of so-called
vaccine mandate conspiracies them on our Instagram
page at David Pakman show.
And if you want to see one of our Dutch viewers
yesterday in a supermarket saw an advertisement
for beer and it looked like I was on the advertisement.
It's actually really strange.
I posted it to my Instagram.
You can find me at David Pakman.